see Cowboys don't swing on parks but
stoeckley you know of were you around in
the 1800s my favorite guy is actually
the guy in the background it goes hey ya
listening
as long as we get paid you get shot I'm
happy we finally played Red Dead
Redemption - I thought the day would
never come good actually play yeah we
played for what two hours was it two
hours there was a bit we're like we had
to toss a coin to decide who would go
first but - rock star they were like
enjoy here's a game so we got to play
like a couple of missions like one was
the main mission I think both were main
missions two of them were the Soyuz
missions on either side start and end of
our demo the first one was epic ending
so the first one they actually paid
played through and then the last one you
played through there's a reason that
they opened it by them playing it yeah
and that's because otherwise like if
we'd gone in and done a mission with no
prior context and no grass with the
controls would have absolutely yeah
which is exactly what you did exactly
what it's like the the the opening
mission without spoiling too much of a
very conscious of about saying too much
about this game given how many people
are excited for ever like it's a robbery
of sorts so you're doing something you
know you're robbing a gang if anybody
you're being a bad guy you want to be a
cowboy baby so then the second part of
it is like if they dump you in the open
world and you can immediately like see
how overwhelming this game is from my
first five minutes for the game because
it is it was a comedy of errors like I
immediately it descended into absolute
chaos for the first thing you did pretty
much I just went to attempt I just went
to a nearby okay oh yeah I know I go on
the horse so the horse was there I got
in the horse and I was like I'll go to
this camp and that's nearby and I walk
into the camp what I didn't know is that
camp belonged to the gang that we robbed
in the previous mission so I walk in and
the guys like what you doing here and I
didn't really pay too much mind I
thought I'll talk to the guy and try and
use the new conversation system where
you hold old who we have we're playing
on ps4 Pro and you lock on and then
you've got the option to kind of like
antagonize greet defuse that kind of
thing so I was like I'll defuse the
situation
I hit a diffuse button
and like it doesn't really work when
you've just robbed these dis gang and so
like he immediately calls for backup
yeah like not like I need backup is like
boys come check this out it's this guy
and then they quickly appear and they
are not messing about they pull out the
gun straight away and start firing and
within seconds my horse is dead I'm like
when I got shot a bunch of times
Arthur's posture and gait changes yeah
so like I'm limping now and like running
is more difficult stamina is not as good
I'm in the middle of a road like I get
far enough and I was like so we thought
I would go to a local town and like
clean up and stuff I mean bearing in
mind you are covered in blood yeah
Oscar's got a black eye now because they
were saying that like there's a lot more
brawling and fist fighting so they've
there's like fast motion up people's
faces all over the shops you would like
at this Stoneking black eye blood so
doctors go under into a town yeah well
there was a guy who came along on a
horse and I like tried to flag him down
and he was like is that your blood nope
and he just carries on like riding so I
did the evil thing which is shot him off
his horse
and try to and you just basically the
other one that's Kelly she's like I sure
gotta go out to a horse and I got on the
his horse and I was riding and there's a
guy comes by with a carriage and I
thought I'll do that thing where I pull
up and their bindings go ahh and Tipler
hat
I pull up nearby I must have pressed the
wrong button because like I blinked and
within seconds I hadn't leaped onto his
carriage and I'm trying to wrestle the
reins of the horse away from him
this guy pistol whips me pushes me off
the the carriage in the distance a
lawman sees it all happen and then
immediately calls his friends and like
I'm being honey there's a one in level
out of me and then I fell off a cliff
so the thing I like in my time with the
demo it's like the thing that I really
enjoyed is that just think the thing
with like Rockstar world's before and
like with Red Dead Redemption before it
was very much like the world existed you
existed
Eden Rini
that much of an impact on what was
happening around you and like what would
happen directly to you with Red Dead - I
felt like every single thing I was doing
was building and the world was reacting
to me a very specific way so like when
you went to so after the bit where
you're all covered in blood you managed
to escape from that craziness that you
admitted or did cause we went to this
hotel and the guy who was running it was
like not you again please like don't I
don't need this today please and like
you as Arthur because you're you control
how you try to them you say look I don't
have a bath yeah and it's like this
really cool it's kind of like it is this
like role playing in a way and I really
enjoyed it because it felt like it was
my Arthur Morgan yeah doing what he was
like I was playing the role that I
wanted him to play and all the
characters were reacting to me in a good
way now shoo please I'm waiting for
someone interesting to turn on it's only
when you played this game that you
realize how how much more there was to
explore in open worlds like Rockstar the
best in the world and it starts like
very few people are gonna argue against
that they create the most compelling and
believable like interesting open worlds
but when you play this you realize how
I'm not saying like GTA 5 was bad but
like you realize how almost like how
that was a facade and how like very kind
of not fake but like it didn't feel real
this feels like it like you feel like an
invisible tourist in in those games
where you walk around and until you do
something outrageous so until you
interact with the world the world
doesn't react to you like if you punch
someone appeals on people around you
will go all and then carry on walking
this doesn't feel like that it feels
like you can just stand still in just a
random area and just there's connections
to the world every piece of the world
around you and things can just naturally
happen and that's the kind of thing
where like if you're standing in the
middle of a pathway and you're covered
in blood people aren't gonna ignore you
until you like you walk up and punch him
they'll see you and some of them will
flee
some of them will comment like all
that's really creepy
yeah and like the way you kind of move
around the world it feels like this like
invisible like strings attached to
everything and like you're just walking
around it's all being pulled and
changing different parts of the world it
felt very very overwhelming and like the
system's like we can talk about now it's
that it's one of those experiences where
I felt bad of a game because it just
there's so much to understand and so
much to to kind of internalize that we
hadn't done yet and I think that's
inherently the problem of like not
playing the beginning because obviously
you get tutorial eyes and you go
walkthrough but then like being like
being put in that world and the thing
that I really enjoyed about it was that
you could once you've got your head
around how everything worked because in
previous rockstar games like there is a
control scheme that you become
inherently like very familiar with over
you know 21 years like playing rockstar
games is that you know that like to get
in or over vehicle or get in yeah it's
triangle you know that it's kind of
stuff like that but there are so many
more layers to it and there's so much
more like in-depth stuff like it's not
just like when you're playing as Arthur
you stand still right and it's not just
your character standing still do nothing
you can like fiddle with your gun you
can do a couple of gun tricks you can
like fan the hammer you can like get a
pair of binoculars out and just take a
look oh and you can do that in
first-person if you want to yeah the
whole game is playable in first-person
like surprise we're just super cool and
it's just like it adds so many more
layers to everything from the very
beginning but one once you kind of
appreciate the the minutiae of stuff
like your weapons getting dirty
you can go wash off in a river you can
go take your horse to the river and like
literally lead them to go to the river
and have a drink and it's like once you
get used to the fact that everything you
do has a consequence and everything you
do like matters yeah it just kind of
feels like this is open-world games it
feels like it does feel like an
evolutionary step the world is just so
reactive to you that this is the kind of
thing that has been
until this point like we've been able to
like we said create these worlds yeah
but like it's the moments in the inside
of it and like filling every single part
of it so it feels a little more
believable that's that kind of has been
missing and the way the world reacts to
Arthur and everything that you do is now
really really like Ratchet it up it it
feels quite overwhelming at times so you
yeah everything to be constantly aware
of everything they need to be constantly
aware of your actions are gonna have
consequences immediately and also down
the line because of like the honor
system
oh really sometimes you can they can run
into an NPC and you can have a weird
interaction with him like you know if
you're covered in blood or something you
any might you know comment on it he
might remember you later on down the
line like because you've had that
interaction them already and like
nowhere I think is it more apparent the
reactionary stuff is in the camp
[Music]
it's like you get to the companies like
a living breathing camp like everyone is
just there hanging about like having the
wrong conversations all the time that's
how you can pick up new missions if we
wanted to or you can just sit by the
campfire and like one of the best
moments I think from our demos that I
love Red Dead Redemption
oh yeah like and John Marston as a
character I think was brilliant I think
he was like a really flawed but
ultimately quite relatable character and
he was very loyal and he was very just
incredible character to latch onto and
so I was really like when when they
announced that this was a prequel and
you wouldn't be planning as John I was a
bit like so great but now playing is
author you get to see John through a
different lens and you get to see a
different version of John and when
you're in the camp you can just like if
you want to even go up and talk to him
and just like find out know how he's
been going and what he's been doing and
its opens up and it adds texture to the
character of John like we should be
talking about Arthur because Arthur is
an important he's the main character and
like there's some really interesting
dynamics already that we saw like Dutch
is the leader but he seems to be very
much a bit of a poser like he's got this
hyphenating idea he's like the
philosopher cowboy who's got these grand
schemes and plans but then they're
nothing without Arthur so that like
Arthur's really important but it's
interesting that because when you play
as him you get a new perspective on John
as well because he's very much quite
flawed and he's becoming the man that we
know later on that he's we meet him and
he's a bit banged up he's out of action
the game is absolutely giving him so
much and like I said oh this is really
interesting take on seeing that
character so like I'm kind of on board
with him not being the main character
now and they said like you won't do a
character switching thing at any point
so I'm really excited to see more of the
of John Marcin and also the other gang
members there's a whole bunch of them
around like Bill's around capture you
know and like you have a really weird
relationship with him as well there's
things like they comment like he doesn't
quite trust you or he clearly is keeping
your arms alone
so there's like really interesting
dynamics and it's like you said when you
go to that camp the game isn't waiting
for you it's not the world isn't waiting
for you you're not the kind of like the
center of attention for everyone it's
just happening it's just it just feels
like you've walked into something like
mid conversation mid mid you know an
event and you can come and go as you
please and the world will continue to
exist and that's something that people
have talked about in a lot of games
before like oh this is a world that
feels living and breathing and without
you with or without you it will carry on
etc etc but this is the first time I've
actually believed it just cause like the
reactivity of everything around you and
I'm kind of that element of it this camp
feels really really alive and that is
incredibly exciting I keep I keep coming
back to it but like the minutia of
things is like when you go when Arthur
like when he brings a room for example
to stay for the night like he can look
at himself in the mirror and so they
were saying you're thinking like that
first gameplay reveal trailer they were
like everything when your horse is like
rendered and physically connected to
your horse and it's the same with all
this clothes and you can like fully
customize how you look and things and
you can shave if you want to do your own
hair and then there's just a time where
there's a moment of reprieve I guess
where Arthur's just like you in how old
ll2 and you look at yourself in the
mirror and he just like comments on him
he's like there's a bit where he looked
in the mirror he goes yeah that's why
they'll leave you he's like wow okay so
like you hold a button and it's like a
press right on the d-pad of the killers
and he would deliver one line and then I
kept pressing it and it started to chain
the loans together too so it sounded
like one kind of like diatribe about
himself the minutiae again like if you
get a haircut you can't it's not that
like that rock star or any open world
customization game thing where you take
you've got a haircut and you're like I
don't like it and then you scroll down
and all the hair is back and you can
change you want to change the haircut
you got wait for it to grow back and if
it's like messy and you've slightly long
you can go to town and buy a pomade and
style it there's stuff like you know the
weapons the weapons are like super like
degradable but like
I think part of it must come from the
fact that it's playable in first-person
now they want that extra level of
details so like you can just like take a
look at you've gone and you can see dirt
building up on it and look they were
saying that like if you take it through
a river or if it gets wet like it lasts
yeah it's just like extra layer but at
the same time obviously we didn't spend
that much time with it I'd be interested
to know like what the balance is like
for that because that that is a lot
going on and also you have cause so
you've got like health you've got
stamina you've got a Deadeye you have
more and like oh yeah things like level
up like your stamina and level up sort
of like how is it in GTA by like by
running more your stamina and increases
and you get better and you can increase
your abilities that way well like these
cause that you can like if you rest for
example or if you take a tonic or
something you can increase them so
there's that to take into account it if
you get cold you'll move differently
you'll move slower like there's a lot to
take on yeah and I know worried because
I've like I'd love to play but like I've
been interested to see how much that
you're gonna have to consciously be on
top of all yeah I mean they talked about
managing the camp right where's like the
camp you you you're required to kind of
up keep it to a certain extent you can
take food yeah health but like it's
never gonna be like critical mission
failure can be about to fall apart and
metal gear survive like game over and
I'm hoping that it's similar to that I
mean there there is a survivalist
element to this game like it shows you
we went into one screen and it was
showing us like our weight so you can
gain weight and lose weight similar to
San Andreas and like you can be a fire
author if you want but it's showing us
stats on like stamina and percentages
and time as well like how long before it
starts to degrade in a noticeable way
and even things like the the kind of
weapon degradation they were like at
some point the game will actually tell
you you need to fix this right until
that point you the way you figure it out
is you'll feel the gun start to behave
differently
like shots won't be as good because
that's the way the game wants to tell
will be slower and like things like the
rifles for example you need to fire and
then [ __ ] and then fire so like that
will become more difficult because of
the degradation so it's trying to kind
of make it natural the way it could like
confers information to you but it also
will do that thing where it's like hey
you need to actually pay attention to
this now
they'll probably hang you the UI is
super clean and it's like it's not that
yeah it's just the map the only thing
that is the me map in the bottom left
sometimes your core pops up like if
you're taking a ton of damage or if
you're on your horse and it's like
running on stamina but like it's not
there all the time if you want to see it
you just like tap down on the d-pad and
then it gives you like a big sort of
info blast about what's going on yeah
when I first got the reins the reins of
the game after you the first thing I did
was I just went to the top of a hill and
just sort of like looked out because
like Red Dead was 2010 and at the time
it was a great looking game like you
play it now on Xbox one it looks great
but obviously it's not it's aged like
compared to what we've seen in games
like The Witcher like these beautiful
landscape stuff and Red Dead - it was
like this is it reminded me of why this
is why I love the original game this is
a world I want to lose myself in and the
fact that it's so beautiful just lends
it yeah so like we when we started we
were in like just this open field we'd
come down from Mounds we could see the
mountains that we were in before and
just a rainstorm appeared out of nowhere
and just kind of we were supposed to be
starting to it they were supposed to
show us how the gunplay works but
because the rainstorm all the birds had
like flown away and the animals were
like kind of taking shower so there's
nothing around this shoot and like one
of the really cool things is like you're
riding and Arthur's you can see his his
clothing is just drenched waterlogged
and he's kind of like if you turn into
the wind where the wind is where the
rain is coming from he'll like dip his
his head and like hold the Hat to kind
of shield his eyes as
as he's writing and you did the hunting
as well and that was yes the mind of
kind of has like a survival instinct you
type thing where you can like silently
take out animals cuz it's more like just
like I don't want to say that Gator huge
focus on stealth and stuff but you can
like yeah you can stuff
stealth stuff you haven't by one hour
now and you can like you can use that
survival instinct and Hughes Deadeye now
to sort of like if you want to make a
clean kills so that you can get more
money for the pelt for example and then
you can use that to give more to your
like the folks at camp like because
everything leads into everything else
right but you can use that and a couple
of survival instinct like you can take a
shot at an animal and then you can sort
of see its blood trail and track it you
can either see that like the blood on
the ground or you can like trigger the
surveillance and keep type thing and at
higher levels stuff like Dead Eye once
it's improved it will show you things
like critical spots way if you hear you
get a really clean instinct kill kill
cam now buddy like slow dynamically pick
a good shot to show you when it's
important everything is like feeding
into other parts of the game and we did
a few missions here and there as we saw
a mysterious stranger mission which was
like we went into a bar and there was
like this guy who was just fully passed
out and drunk and another guy who's
trying to get information out of him it
turns out the guy was trying to get
information is writing a book about this
gunslinger who's supposed to be a
legendary gunslinger but he's just not
having it because he's passed out so
he's this guy's like I need to write
this gunslinger book can you find these
other legendary gunslingers and take a
picture of him if they put up any fight
just kill him so effectively is it's
like here's an assassin mission taking
out these legendary gunslingers and it
was a multi-part mission which means we
couldn't actually do it in time so we
kind of liked but those mysterious
stranger missions are around like weird
but the weird parts of the read dead
world are still going to be there I
would be shocked if there's not like
some sort of West world reference or a
robot reference given the whole Bigfoot
Sasquatch thing there but the last game
this is God's own country and I feel I'm
in purgatory I think it's one of those
like I will play this for probably a
long time I feel confident about it now
it's been so long and I was starting to
get worried about it but I mean like my
worry was misplaced it seems from what
we've played so far man like eight plus
years this games been in Zona I'm like
road dead is one of my favorite games
and so coming out of this I feel good
feels good man yeah and like we're sorry
because this video we know has gone on
but you can kind of tell from what you
know our experience with two hours of
the game there is so much more there's a
lot yeah we there's still stuff though
we haven't covered because we don't
understand even talked about the horses
pooping everywhere horses can poop
dressage if you're if you're bonded
enough of it you know what I want to be
a cowboy
[Music]